I'm a little bit older. So perhaps I have a different perspective.
I've been married 21 years. You've been some.
Very difficult times. I'm assuming in your marriage.
Absolutely. Absolutely. You have to work and fight for you,
fight for your marriage.
And coming outta that.
Wasn't that the portion that made you love your partner the most?
Absolutely. Let me just share this because I, I, I know a lot of people who,
who want, who wanna have a relationship and connect the four things that kill a
relationship. People never talk about, go for it.
And those things are criticism. When you constantly criticize your partner,
you're gonna kill your relationship. That's number one, number two contempt.
When you get to a place of contempt for your partner,
that's a sign that your relationship is going to fail. Uh, number three,
when you are defensive, you are constantly your partner.
Can't point something out to you in a, in a loving way. Just even,
even sometimes it's hard, but if you're constantly defensive and it's like,
it's like a moving target, nobody could get to you. That's a sign.
And the last one last one is, um, how can I say this? It's like stonewalling,
right? It's like the, that Drawbridge goes up and it's like, no,
no, yeah, no. Can I ask.
You, can I ask something? Can I ask you bro? Go ahead bro.
Aren't wouldn't you say that all those things are choices.
All of those things are choices and you have to accept the
responsibility, right?
That you are responsible for your behavior.
That's the thing. It, it, it's not about, you can feel how you want to,
and maybe you need to process and work through your feelings, right?
To understand why you feel the way that you do. But irrespective of that,
you are still responsible for your be behavior.
You're responsible for the things that you say you're responsible for the things
that you do. Hey.
Hey, you preach it to the choir. My friends, you know what I mean? I, I, listen,
you're not the only one,
pretty much every married couple that I would speak to that you research online
that you look at studies will say the same thing. Right?
And so that's why it's crazy to me. When people talk about like, right, well,
what am I gonna preach to the marriage? But they never bring up responsibility.
No, they.
Never respect labor.
It's a lot of.
Labor. Hard. We have two, we have twins. It's hard. It's, that's,
don't preach. It's not a party. It's not gonna be that.
You're gonna get your way all the time.
It's not gonna be tiptoeing through the tulips. Nah, it is.
And here's the thing too. A lot of times, as a married person,
you have to remind yourself, oh yeah, you know what? This is not about me.
I have this responsibility to my wife, to my children,
to the legacy of my family, to my community,
do need to change the culture because, because talking about legacy,
right, right. In what I'm gonna leave to my children,
what I'm gonna leave to my grandchildren beginning to plan and think about these
things will help me understand that, oh, you know what?
Buying those Jordans is probably not the wisest thing for me to do.
It's better for me to take that money.
If we're talking about finances mm-hmm <affirmative> and go invest that into
Nike. Let let's just use that. For example,
mm-hmm <affirmative> and that money will be there for my grandchild versus me
wearing these JS for, you know, let's say I have 'em for six months.
Like mm-hmm,
<affirmative> what's six months when we're talking about legacy mm-hmm
<affirmative> so, so these are the kinds of things that, and when,
when you're bonded with your partner about legacy and you're now starting to
plan and plot about, Hey, what we gonna do for our kids?
What are we gonna do for our grandkids? What are we gonna do?
That changes the dynamic of how you see your partner.
It changes the dynamic about what the institution of marriages.
It helps you understand your marriage is connected to more than just your
emotion, your feelings it's connected to not just you,
not just your kids, but your community that's right, right.
It's a reflection of something much, much bigger. So anyway,
I just wanted to share those things.
You have to understand what it is before you go into it,
because I'm sure when you take those vows, you understood what it meant. Well,
not only that, my wife and I, we sat down, we went to counseling,
let's put all our cards on the table and we,
and when we hit a rough patch and we feel like, Hey, you know what?
Our relationship isn't as dynamic as it should be. For example, uh,
after we had our twins, right? It's like,
we have to learn how to reconnect because for the first three, four years,
we just so twins. You know what I mean? Trying to stay above water. Yes, sir.
Wait, wait, are you saying that you had three,
four years of turbulence and you stuck through it? Of course. Right.
But it's it's it was difficult,
but we had to sit down and we had to say to one another, Hey, if you're.
Wondering why I'm dancing so hard it's cuz somebody came on earlier and they
were like, yeah, well, if I was happier for two multiple years,
I would just leave him. And wholely.
Okay. Yeah. Well, you keep on doing that. And after that,
you wonder why after all these year you're unhappy like this,
this guy right there. I don't know what your name is, sir,
but for the purpose of all this, I'm gonna call you preach.
So what preach is saying right now <laugh> but the else,
you want me to say, when a preach, my name is preach,
but when another is preach, I'm gonna is preaching. I'm gonna be like, okay,
sure. Take on the flame and preach on bro.
I got nothing else to add to whatever the hell you was saying.
Preach preach was doing a good job right now. Yo, listen, this,
this video you're showing me, you're showing me. I been preach.
You showing me a preach. Yes. Like, you know, it would be.
Hilarious if there would be like a bald preach reveal. And it's just this guy,
<laugh>.
A British guy. Look like him bald too.
But it is what it is at the end of the day. He said what? He said,
he's talking a rough patches. He's talking about the yo it's you're unhappy.
You leave.
I then you're always gonna end up leaving because people have this idea of
this picture. Perfect image. A wedding could be perfect. A
it's a whole other ball game. What's gonna make a decision. If I state is,
if the other one wants to, is willing to work. That's the thing.
If you're willing to work, if you're willing to, if you're,
if you're willing to work,
if you're not willing to work or the other person is not willing to work,
then there's nothing much you could do about it.
Person doesn't want to give the effort. If you're telling me I'm AAP,
I'm happy because the person doesn't wanna put the effort.
Therefore there's nothing that works because I there's.
There's like he's talking about it. He's talking about content.
And he's talking about that bridge coming up.
That's the other person not wanting to work. Then I can understand leaving.
But if you're unhappy and you're talking about it and you don't stick you
through it, I'm not even talking about something that toxic.
I'm not talking about something that stalls by all means, boo.
If it's toxic leave, that's some different.
If it's affecting your mantle and stuff like that leave. But if when you,
when you want to make that contract and the both person
willing to work on it, that's a different thing. So it's like when I was saying,
you know,
that's speed has never caused any death when you're driving your car
and anybody that's been driving, it is not the speed that's causing death.
It's the sudden stop. You know what I mean? That's what caused death.
It's been the same day in the marriage. It,
it's not you getting there and having things happening and wanting to work.
It's when someone stops and doesn't wanna work no more.
That is a death of the, the relationship. Really? The person's not willing.
The person's always right. The person is the person that yeah, he said,
he said what? He said.
This is what you're noticing from the female perspective.
This is what I'm noticing from the male perspective.
And the conclusion is we are not connected as we would like to be.
So now that we are in a place where we have the,
the time and the resources in our relationship, Hey, let's,
let's go to counseling. I recommend counsel, especially for black people,
we need counseling, but, but everyone. So we went to counseling and said, okay,
these are the things that we need to work on.
These are the things that we need to do. Can I just share one more thing? Yes.
That might be helpful. Yeah. Wrap this up please. Um, I'll wrap it up.
One more thing. Yes. I think it's very, very important as well,
to be self aware Uhhuh when you're single and know what it is that
you need in a woman or in a man, right? What are your weaknesses?
What are your strengths? You're dating a, you're dating a person.
What are they bringing to the table in terms of character in terms of character.
And, and that is, that is huge.
So that's how you pick the right person for you. Right. You know,
and that takes a lot of self awareness that takes, you know,
putting sex to the side and, and, and really focusing on, okay,
who is this person as an individual human being? Who is it? Because guess what?
You should be able to marry this person.
If they don't change a lick for the next 40 years,
the person that you see right in front of you, if they don't,
if they decide I'm not changing, can you marry this person? And,
and looking at character is, is, is I,
I guess what I'll say is that's a, one of the areas where we're failing is we,
we, we think sex and we think good time.
We think that's not what holds a marriage together.
If looks is not what holds a marriage together,
all these things are very superficial. So anyways, that's what I wanna say.
And just share that.
Thank you so much. I appreciate you coming on. All right.
That's it for today's video. I mean, he said what he said, I'm not, <laugh> the.
You want me to say BR? He said some, some of the I said before, it's like, it,
it really is what it is. It it's,
that's it for today's video share like contract. But yo, that's what it is.
Whenever they're trying to find, someone's like, oh, we have the same interest.
He likes burn. Boy. I like burn. Boy. That's not gonna raise a family.
That's not gonna do anything for you later on when gonna be hard,
money's gonna be tight. You need, you need someone that's gonna be able to,
to manage. You're gonna be able to someone that's gonna have to you're back.
That's gonna be that after that, you got the little, you got the sex scare.
That all that is nice, but you can't be all the time.
You're not gonna be always having intercourse. That's not what a marriage is.
It's hard. It's rough. Nobody's perfect in that. It's,
everybody's got their flaws and everything and stuff,
but it's really what you are willing to work. If you're willing to work.
That's what it is. This guy was preaching right there. That's to me,
that's another preach. I don't know your name. I don't know what it is.
And I don't care, frankly. Dear, I don't give a to me. You was preaching.
Therefore, your name is preach. He did that.
That's a dude that knows. Now. I'm not even gonna say that.
Like he applies everything. I don't know the man,
but we are so caught up in ideals and stuff like that.
None of that is going to raise anything. It's a plus.
It's a plus. Yeah.
They like the same music as you fine. That's a plus, but that's not.
What's gonna raise a family. If you see my wife, you know her,
I'd say polar opposites, polar opposites.
The goal is the same. The fact is the same.
It hasn't always been easy. You're willing to work in.
He said what? He said, this guy was, this guy was pitting games. God.
God bless you, sir. Yeah. He came in and was spitting facts. I don't,
I didn't hear, I didn't hear one like in,
in his speech still going on, you know, like, you know, he came in and was like,
listen, this what it is. Yo, talk your, sir.
Right. Look let's it for today's video.
Let know what you guys thought about the comments.
Hold
I.